63 a five-minute portion of president
john f kennedy's state of the union
address
vice president mr speaker
members of the 88th congress
i congratulate you all
not merely in your electoral victory
but on your selected role in history
but you and i are privileged to serve
the great republic
in what could be the most decisive
decade
in its long history
the choices we make for good or ill
will affect the welfare of generations
yet unborn
little more than 100 weeks ago
i assumed the office of the president of
the united states
in seeking the help of the congress
and our countrymen
i pledge no easy answers
i pledged and asked
only toil and dedication
these the congress and the people
have given in good measure
and today having witnessed in recent
months
a heightened respect
for our national purpose and power
having seen the courageous calm
of a united people
in a perilous hour
and having observed a steady improvement
in the opportunities and well-being of
our citizens
i can report to you
that the state of this old but youthful
union is good
[Applause]
in the world beyond our borders
steady progress has been made in
building a world of order
the people of west berlin remain free
and secure
[Applause]
a settlement though still precarious
has been reached in laos the spear point
of aggression has been blunted
in south vietnam
the end of the agony may be in sight in
the congo
the doctrine of troika is dead
and while danger continues
a deadly threat has been removed from
cuba
for we seek not the worldwide victory of
one nation or system
but a worldwide victory of men
the modern globe is too small
its weapons are too destructive
they multiply too fast
and its disorders are too contagious
to permit any other kind of victory
to achieve this end
the united states will continue to spend
a greater portion of its national
production than any other people in the
free world
for 15 years
no other free nation has demanded so
much of itself
through hot wars and cold
through recession and prosperity
through the ages of the adam and outer
space
the american people have neither faulted
nor has their faith flagged
if at times our actions
seem to make life difficult for others
it is only because history has made life
difficult for us all
[Music]
[Applause]
but difficult days need not be dark
i think these are proud and memorable
days
in the cause of peace
and freedom
we are proud for example
of major rudolph anderson who gave his
life over the island of cuba
[Applause]
we salute specialist james allen johnson
who died on the border of south korea
we pay honor to sergeant gerald pendle
who was killed in vietnam
[Applause]
they are among the many
who in this century
far from home
have died for our country
our task now and the task of all
americans
is to live up to their commitment
my friends i close on a note of hope
we are not loved by the momentary calm
of the sea
or the somewhat clear skies above
we know the turbulence that lies below
and the storms that are beyond the
horizon this year
but now the winds of change
appear to be blowing more strongly than
ever
in the world of communism
as well as our own
for
175 years
we have sailed with those winds at our
back
and with the tides of human freedom in
our favor
we steer our ship with hope
as thomas jefferson said
leaving fear astern
today we still welcome those winds of
change
and we have every reason to believe
that our tide is running strong
with thanks to almighty god
for seeing us through a perilous passage
we ask his help anew
in guiding the good ship union
[Applause]